حظي يا بسمه وداعا تويتر وارقد بسلام
تويتر باهتمام واسع عبر المنصات العالميه
جاء ذلك بعد قرارات المدير الجديد للمنصه
الى الماسك التي ادت لاستقاله المئات خلال
الساعات الاخيره وكان عدد من موظفي فطر قد
وثقوا عبر حساباتهم الشخصيه على المنصه
امس الخميس
استقالاتهم من الشركه وافادوا ان المنصه
تشهد مئات الاستقالات بعد لفظهم التوقيع
على التعهد الذي عرضه الى الماسك عليهم
قبل يومك كان ماسك قد اصدر انذارا لموظفين
تويتر طالبهم فيه بالعمل بجديه اكبر
وزياده ساعه العمل واعتبر ربهم التوقيعه
اقرارا بفصلهم من الشرك
وقد ابلغت اداره تويتر موظفيها ان مكاتب
الشركه ستغلق باثر فوري وبشكل مؤقت على ان
تفتح في الحادي والعشرين من نوفمبر تشرين
الثاني الجاري حسبما افادت وكاله رويترز
وقدت صحيفه واشنطن بوست ان هذا الاجراءات
ياتي بعد انتهاء الموعد الذي منحه الى
الماسك لموظفي الشركه للتوقيع على تعهد
بالعمل ساعات اضافيه او طلب انهاء خدمتهم
اضافتي الصحيفه ان الكثير من التساؤلات
تثار داخل الشركه عن قدره الموقع على
الاستمرار في العمل في ظل القرارات التي
يتخذها ماسك كما نقلت عن موظفينا سابقين
وحاليين ان عددا كبيرا من زملائهم قرروا
الاستقاله ومنهم مهندسون يشرفون على انظمه
حساسه في الشركه وقد ناقش مغردون عبر
الوصول قدره من تويتر على الاستمرار في ظل
ما اعتبروه نقصان كبيرا في عدد الموظفين
كما ودع الالاف منهم المنصه التي وغضبوا
عليها لسنوات تحسبا لن هيارها في اي لحظه
كتب صحفي جورجلي اورسيز
بتغريده له طبعا كتب الشيء الايجابي
الوحيد فيما يحدث لتويتر هو اننا نرى ما
يحدث عندما تعامل
الموظفون بالزراء وعدم احترام او عندما
تعامل الموظفين بالزراء وعدم احترام حين
لا تتواصل معهم تطرد نصفهم تغير ظروف
العمل دون سابق انذار تطرد اليك الذين
ينتقدونك
وعلق الموظف السابق في الشركه امير
الشيفات بالقول في تغريده له الجزء المحزن
في هذه القصه هو اننا كنا نتطلع الى
الانتقال من حاله عدم اليقين الى بناء
المنتج الذي نحبه كان من الممكن ان يكون
الامر مختلفا مع القليل من التواضع
والاحترام
والتواصلي المهني